مراسل الجزيره هيثم ابرز ما سجلته حتى
اللحظه هيثم
نعم ابرز ما نشاهده او نتابعه الان كما
تسمعون الان يعني الاشتباكات على اشدها
الخرطوم لليوم الثالث على التوالي تستيقظ
على اصوات هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
الاصوات الكبيره للذخيره والانواع الاسلحه
المختلفه بدات منذ صباح الباكر يعني
اشتباكات او قذائف يبدو انها من المدفعيه
الثقيله كانت
تستهدف هذه المناطق حول سواء كان بالقرب
من القصر او النيل شاهدنا العديد من
القذائف سقطت داخل النيل وايضا في احياء
بحري كما يمكن المشاهده من خلال السنه
الدخان المتصاعده في منطقه البحري هناك
كانت ايضا يعني شهدت ساحه من وقوع بعض
القذايف على ما يبدو ولكن الان ما يحدث
الان هو اشتباك يبدو مباشر بشكل لانه واضح
من خلال هذه الاصوات ان الاسلحه هي اسلحه
متوسطه
وثقيله لكنها مستمره منذ اكثر من ساعه او
ساعتين هذه الاشتباكات مستمره على تخوم
القصر الرئاسي فيما يبدو او منطقه وسط
الخرطوم ايضا افادنا مسؤول طبي قبل قليل
من مستشفى الشعب احدى هذه القذائف سقطت في
معمل المستشفى الشعب المركزي المركزي هنا
وقد اصاب يعني بعض الاشخاص وحاله هلع
اصابه المواطنين داخل المستشفى وانهم بعض
المرضى يعني بداوا بالفرار من المستشفى
هذا بحسب المسؤوله الطبي من المستشفى الذي
تحدث للجزيره قبل قليل الان يعني حاله
هلعت تتجدد وسط الخرطوم يعود ليشهد مره
اخرى هذه الاصوات وهذه الاشتباكات
المستمره التي يعني منذ ثلاثه ايام ما
زالت مستمره بهذه الوتيره يعني في في لا
ندري يعني الى اي متى ستستمر هذه الاشتباك
هذه الذخائر كما تسمعون الاصوات يعني
تزداد شيئا فشيئا ما يعني اشتداد المعارك
في في هذا الجانب رغم يعني
الدعوات العديده لوقف التصعيد ووقف اطلاق
النار ولكن على الارض فيما يبدو حتى الان
صوت السلاح والاعلى وصوت هذه الذخائر هو
الذي يعلو على كل اصوات اخرى تنادي
بالتهدئه وتنادي بخفض التصعيد وتنادي
بالجلوس والجنوح الى الحوار وحل هذه
المشكلات بطريقه سلميه او وديه او حتى
التحركات الدوليه التي يتم التحدث عنها
حتى الان لم يفصح عن يعني متى مثلا سيصل
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي او الرئيس
الروساء دوله السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي
لمحاوله نزع فتيل الازمه القائمه الان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الجيش كان قد
اعلن انه يعني فرض سيطرته بالكامل على
الوضع وانه قام بتدمير العديد من مقر قوات
الدعم وانه يسيطر وان ساعه النصر قد
اقتربت ولكن حتى الان الدعم السرعي ايضا
يرد بالمثل ذات البيانات انه ايضا يسيطر
على المواقع الاستراتيجيه وانه يقاوم
الجيش وهذه هي الحاله التي تعيشها الخرطوم
منذ ثلاثه ايام ولكن
انعكاسات كل هذا الوضع بالتاكيد يصب او
يتحمله او مواطن الخرطوم ومواطنين السودان
في عدد من المدن جراء هذه الازمه التي
ازمه امنيه خلفت ازمه انسانيه الان يعاني
منها العديد
من المدنيين الذين هم محتجزون في يعني
العديد من الاماكن في وسط الخرطوم في في
مقر سواء كانت مكاتب عمل او مقارن تجاريه
او
منازل او مستشفيات او مدارس يعني شرائح
عديده من المجتمع الان تعيش ظروف
استثنائيه وظروف صعبه لثلاثه ايام البعض
منهم لم يحصل على الماء او الطعام يعني
سمعنا هناك ايضا مرضى يحتاجون الى اسعاف
يحتاجون الى الوصول الى المستشفيات لتلقي
العلاج وفي المقابل لجنه الاطباء المركزيه
تناشد وتستغيث بانه نقص الكوادر الان هو
المشكله الكبرى تواجه المستشفيات وتواجه
المرضى الذين يتوافدونه اليها رغم يعني
هذا الوضع الماثل امامنا ولكن الان الوضع
الماثل هو هذه الاصوات وهذه الاشتباكات
التي لا يعلم احد الى اي متى الى اي مدى
ستستمر والى متى ستنتهي ومتى ستنتهي هذه
كلها امور الان تحددها هذه الاشتباكات
التي تزداد كما تسمعون من لحظه الى اخرى
هل اختلفت هذه الاشتباكات خلال ساعات
الصباح عما جرى في الساعه الاولى منذ
بدايه هذا التصادم ان كان ما يتعلق بوتيره
الاشتباكات او بنوعيه الاسلحه هيثم
نعم حالات يعني في الليله كان هناك هدوء
يعني يخيم على هذه المنطقه
في الحقيقه منذ مساء الامس من لحظه
الافطار او قبل الافطار كانت هناك يعني
هدوء يستمر لساعات طويله وايضا استمر
لساعات الليل في منطقه دروس الخرطوم
تحديدا ولكن يبدو ان هذا الهدوء كان هو
التجهيز لهذه المعركه التي تدور الان فيما
يبدو لان منذ الصباح الباكر هذا الهجوم هو
الاعنف منذ ان بدات هذه
المعارك هذه الاشتباكات هي الاعنف لانه
الان يعني نسمع الاشتباكات من اتجاهات
عديده ومن جهات مختلفه يعني اكثر من من
جانب ما يعني ان وتييرتها اختلفت نوعيه
السلاح يبدو انه ايضا اختلف
المشاركين فيها ربما اتوا من محاور مختلفه
لا ندري من يقاتل من في اي موقع ومن
المسيطر ومن المهاجم هذه كلها يعني تفاصيل
لا لا نملكها ولكن ما نعرفه الان هو هذه
الاصوات المستمره وهذا الاشتباك القائمه
الان شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم مراسل
الجزيره هيثم